طلبت تايلور سويفت من معجبيها التخلص منها
فركضوا بها إلى
متجر الأسهم، لذا رقصت السماعات وتقفز
كثيرًا لدرجة أنها تسببت في
زلزال حقيقي في سياتل، حسنًا،
توم فورمان من شبكة سي إن إن هو الرجل الوحيد الذي يمكنه
شرح كيف حدث هذا، توم فورمان.  هذا
صحيح، هذا صحيح، لقد ذهبوا للتخلص منه
وهزوه، وهذا ما
حدث هنا، ما حدث هو أن كل هؤلاء
الأشخاص بدأوا بالقفز أثناء
الأغنية، كل الضربات السريعة، وهناك
يمكنك رؤية ما فعلوه وتسببوا في ما
يعادل  زلزال بقوة 2.3 درجة
أثناء قفزهم في
ملعب لومين هناك في سياتل، وهذا
مهم الآن في سياتل على وجه الخصوص
لأنه كان لديهم شيء مثل هذا
قبل العودة في عام 2011، كان سي هوكس في
مباراة فاصلة للبطاقات البرية وقام مارشون
لينش الظهير بأداء
مذهل  ما يقرب من 70 ياردة من الركض ضد قديسي الحبيب،
لذلك سيكون لدينا لحظة
صمت لذلك، لكنها كانت
ركضة رائعة وقد خلق الناس في ذلك الوقت
نفس النوع من رد الفعل الزلزالي هناك، وهو ما يحدث
عندما يقوم باحث في
غرب واشنطن  ألقت الجامعة
نظرة على هذا، قالت جيولوجية نعم
الشيء هو أن الزلزال السريع أكبر
من الزلزال الوحشي الآن هذه المقاييس
هنا لا تبدو صحيحة تمامًا بطريقة ما
لأن المقياس الموجود في الأسفل هو
مقياس أقصر ولكن مع ذلك
الزلزال السريع  كان بالتأكيد أكبر من
الزلزال الوحشي، وبالطبع جميع
الطيور السريعة سعيدة بهذا الأمر